hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation high-throughput production
of auto incidents for rapid detection of
multiple autoimmune diseases presented
by Amin shoe professor and medicine
professor and pharmacology and pharmacy
and director of state key laboratory of
pharmaceutical biotechnology University
of Hong Kong hi I'm Alexis Krause
elaborate and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about our sponsor
please visit www.freddyandeddy.com
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit please
join me in welcoming dr. Amin Joo I will
now turn the presentation over to him
hello everyone thank you for joining my
presentation so my laboratory at the
university of hong kong - will focus on
the biomarker discovery and also
development of high-throughput assays
and also serve up utica and antibodies
and proteins for chronic diseases such
as diabetes autoimmune disease and the
cancer so today so I'm going to share
with you our experience on how to use
particular virus to produce a high
quality other antigens for diagnostic
purpose so what I'm going to do today so
I will firstly please introduce you and
then about the
autoimmune disease what is autoimmune
disease and then I will elaborate and
neither will amount of what is occurring
the challenges for diagnosis of
autoimmune disease and then the
strategies we are adopting to for these
challenges and also and then the last
several minutes of my talk and I will
give you some examples of our how to use
their other antigens we debug express or
develop high-throughput assays for
simultaneous detection of multiple
autoimmune disease so although immune
disease as you know is actually occurs
at anywhere in our body so this acronym
is say our immune system actually
mistakenly recognize our own proteins
our own tissues as they invading
pathogens and then initiate email attack
so up to now Arkansas over 80 types of
autoimmune disease in our body have been
detected even for example in the United
States the over 23 meaning of patients
and with these autoimmune disease
actually incidence is increasing rapidly
in these days so there they ought only
mainly this one of the unique feature
happening unlike other productivities
again the ephemeral as much higher
incidence of autoimmune disease the mail
and if you look all the almost all the
different categories of autoimmune
disease and the female has significant
higher incidence the male
so there are 78 percent of Indians a
good Enfamil but only 22% occurs in male
though that are they autoimmune disease
are classified into two general
categories there is a systemic disorder
so we have Auto antibodies that against
true that is not specific to Auto
antigen
in any tissues fund so that is including
these 70s others and that well I will
mention later on and there are also the
second category we call these localized
disorders to other antibody are specific
to our organ or particular tissues such
as type 2 diabetes and also thyroiditis
and also autoimmune hepatitis so they
are activating all the pathogenesis the
cause of autoimmune disease it is quite
complicated involves many components
from Galactica factors every Galactica
factors cut marker builders and the
environmental factors and other
inflammatory factors and then there
actually these factors consider eyes and
then for the development of autoimmune
disease and there are many types of
immune cells are involved in
pathogenesis of autoimmune disease and
then including this unit they are all
these major cells involving in innate
immunity and the major type of cells
involving or adaptive immunity also each
of these autoimmune disease they have
its own people unique personalities for
the generally oldest immunity immunity
under an adaptive immunity play a role
so at the early stage the over
activation of innate immunity can causes
the filters in the certain tissues and
then we need the self antigen and then
trickle the adaptive immunity and then
causes the targeted filters and also the
tissue damage and the onset of auto
immune disease again one of the unique
feature for these autoimmune disease
again they have the family aggravation
of family Custer and there are two types
of
Esther's in the Arcana havens in that
why is called we call familiar
autoimmunity to in this case for example
in the left side is panel this mother
she has full and then subjectivity no
side and then risk genes and then he her
she has the autoimmune disease an
autoimmune as a disease but her three
kids I can have a different autoimmune
disease in the second case in that we
call this poly
autoimmunity so in that case the mother
herself is actually healthy but she has
risk gene and then hurts
for keys for example monkeys is healthy
and other other cities they have given
to autoimmune disease as you can see
from this case Romania autoimmunity and
the Pony autoimmunity so this suggests
the autoimmunity the pathogenesis is
quite complicated to highlight the
complexity of this autoimmune led and
then you need a high-throughput
screening measures to detect a wide
spectrum of autoimmune disease in the
general population so they are diagnosis
of autoimmune disease at least rather
complicated so according to America's
autoimmune disease that it is
association the ladies that is it shows
the autoimmune disease patient journey
it takes almost five years and to see at
least five doctors before a proper
diagnosis can be made as you know
therefore most of the disease and then
the initial tableau letís start with the
symptoms develop patients and we sleep
with any symptoms they were go to see a
doctor and then study with the medical
examiner
but in for the majority of the
autoimmune disease actually the symptoms
are not very typical and then they're
either like fat ego or other symptoms
and then toddlers or patients open a
glow they open develop until they
develop a very severe complications and
then the doctors you can be made so in
that case so they so they but now you
there's a common technology of
diagnostic measures for autoimmune
disease as you know is they are so you
use all day I immuno detection to detect
the autoimmune antibodies in the
circulation so however so we have faced
many challenges in using is autonomy are
this technology well major challenges is
the sensitivity facility and accuracy so
all you have a lot of this type lucic
product in the market however so what
they auto antigens use in the market
mainly are produced from bacteria so
this material expressed protein often
next the proper epitopes that resembles
the endogenous proteins in our body
therefore so this cannot be recognized
properly by the auto antibodies in our
body so this causes decreased
sensitivity and also they are the
compromised accuracy so the second
challenge for the title allistic of
these autoimmune diabetes autoimmune
disease is the leg acne of the
pathogenic biomarker the most of these
they're Auto antibodies or other
antigens we're detecting actually is
only the consequence of the disease so
do not provide any pathogenic inside and
and another challenges at actually no
throughput screening and this I will
elaborate and interview them later on
so in my lab laboratory the first thing
we want to do and we want try to find
the new biomarkers and which has a
higher sensitivity and the highest
passivity for this autoimmune disease
and I just in this case I will give this
the autoimmune diabetes as an example
how can we use our platform to discover
the level the biomarkers for better
diagnosis so as you know the autoimmune
diabetes is caused by the so the
language the complete disruption of our
pancreatic beta-cells due to the auto
immunity at this stage the diagnosis of
autoimmune diabetes relies on several
auto antibodies in our circulation and
there is specific to our pancreatic a
bit eyelid such as this Auto antibodies
against a gas and I a to
iaa and O's is ring PA be our TBA so
because they are these diagnosis
requires a very high sensitivity the
majority of laboratories in the world
but now the using the radio immuno art
acoustic measures and then in their case
we need the video item so for the
detection as you know in this causes a
lot of inconvenience because of the
short half-life and also they
radioactivity hazard and there are only
a few lab are the small portion of the
clinical diagnostic lip the body can do
that and even that and then the
detection rate is only about the 50 to
70 to 80 percent and also you can only
detect this at the very native stage
so because there is a a couple years ago
there is a paper published in Nature
Medicine shows this neutral feel
actually play a very important role in
the initiation of the auto immune
diabetes and then as you know this
neutrophils is the first line of innate
immune cells and these neutrophils
actually concourses and attack the they
attack of pathogens and them by net
formation by reducing the to the major
proteases and that including is
neutrophil elastase and also the protein
l3 and these two are proteases and then
play an important role in the
inflammation and during the news of your
function therefore and then to see
whether allow these two serum processes
has any Titleist ik value for autoimmune
disease and then we use the pipeline and
that as well established in our
laboratory for generation of acids so in
my laboratory so we have established a
comprehensive platform ranging from
Omega space biomarker discovery using
meta parameters proteomics and that in
our several of our established clinical
study cohort and then for the by the
expression of proteins using different
systems such as you coli menu system and
the East and also in sexist and now we
can generate the antibodies either from
the polygon antibody sources or molecule
antibodies and then we developed
different as a form it starting from
traditional Eliza and then to the
chemiluminescence base the high
sensitivity and the highest reporter and
the immuno
turbulence space as a
and also sleep with as it as I elaborate
later on and then we validate our asses
in our clinical study code and in this
case and we use the Millennial
expression system for this expression of
AE and the PR 3 because these two
proteins they actually be a post
translationally modified so we
successfully express the protein using
the Millennial expression system and it
generated the high specific acid so
afterwards we evaluated our asses in
patients with type autoimmune disease
with different durations and that as you
can see from here compared with healthy
individual and those patients with newly
inserted diabetes as you can see the
first panel of the figure they have much
higher concentration of AE and that is
neutral field electors and also much
higher concentration of PR 3 and then
this concentration actually gradually
decline after they add a day three and
five years so than suggesting to these
through PI markers are involved in the
onset all day during the early stage of
the disease and you can use that for
early diagnosis and then we also
developed this the biochemical
essentially in the medical ID for these
two day and for these two markers and
find a similar pattern and the most
importantly we found this super market
concentration closely associated with
positivity of those classical auto
antibodies detected in autoimmune
diabetes patients and is clearly
suggesting to these patients these two
pi markers can be used for acne risk
prediction and also early detection of
autoimmune disease and then we actually
are now collaborating with many clinical
centers to do the further validation and
the promote is clinical application and
because is two biomarkers and we find
this is closely associated with a de
pasión autoimmunity and the compare with
the classical biomarkers and this
biomarker actually help provide the
Paschal jealous inside and is more
sensitive and also accurate and also
more effective or diagnosis of
autoimmune disease so that is actually
they are effort how to develop the new
biomarkers for autoimmune disease and in
the seventh part so I'm going to discuss
how to use the particular virus system
for high-throughput expression of
recombinant
Auto antigens that can closely resemble
the lateral antigens in our body and for
that elusive purpose so they are they
are autoimmune diseases a class can be
generally classified into two classes so
one is systemic autoimmune disease or
systemic disorders so in this case the
auto antibodies are not specific to any
auto antigens found in certain tissues
so these are can include seven major
classes including this SLE finger
symbols may mix the collective tissues
are diseases and then sister systemic
sclerosis and also p.m. and diem so the
diagnosis of these systemic autoimmune
disease we actually realize on those
Auto antibodies belong to a specific you
knew
category we call this anti-nuclear
antibodies to the second class of
autoimmune disease we call this
localized autoimmune disease so in this
case the auto antibodies are specific to
our organ or a particular tissue such as
these autoimmune diabetes and then
autoimmune hepatitis and then there are
a lot the over acne ad localized
autoimmune disease and then for this
person and so each of these systemic
autoimmune diseases such as SEO ye and
then SS and the mixed connective tissue
diseases each that agent there are many
of these Auto antibodies against the
specific antigens has already been
discovered so this is acne where
established for example for this Sao E
and we have there over around 40 to 90
percent of the detection rate of
prevalence rates and that for these are
so different Auto antibodies again
against different other antigens they
have different detection rate but each
patients they are different so their
fault is important to have a force
balance of these auto antibodies are
detected in these patients because these
systemic autoimmune disease they are
often interrelated and the patients with
all one auto immune disease often hustle
other and then they also have the family
clusters for example these patients as
EoE and then maybe the family members
there are other family members they have
other systemic autoimmune disease so
therefore one of the purpose of our
study so we want try to express their
auto antigen
they can be used for detection all these
autoimmune antibodies simultaneously and
that so we choose the particular virus
for this purpose and the wider
particular virus the assembly because a
lot of these autoantigens I mentioned in
the previous slide actually they are
post-translation are modified they're
the molecular size actually quite big
they are oven insoluble is not soluble
if you use affect your expression system
and but if you use the many expression
system and then the ear is open high and
then the cost is it's not the cost
effective and then it's not so easy to
promote the clinical application
therefore that we choose a particular
virus system to express in the insect
cells because the particular virus also
cut these insect cells can also have
probe post translational modifications
and that furthermore compared with this
many expression system and then these
have additional several spontaneous is
much more efficient and also have very
high yield and the lower cost compared
many expression system and before that
and then we introduced I want to give
you a very brief background about these
particular virus infection and the in
sexual expression system so the
particular virus and once they start
infected the insect cells and then it's
mainly composed of the three stages and
that early stage so the virus will get
into the cells and then in the first six
hours and then this will get the insect
cells prepared for virus replication and
that's at the latest stage and this
virus
this will produce the body the virus is
BiBi to the body the virus actually is
responsible for infections of
communications between tissues and the
cells and that every Nate stage and that
two major proteins polyhedron proteins
and also pitting proteins are produced
and these will produce the big virus
particle we call occlusion body virus
that is ODB this up ruling body virus as
we is responsible for infections between
individuals and then these happily the
particular virus insert self expression
system and take advantage actually this
strong expression of the two major
proteins that is pouring single proteins
and also PM proteins and these two
proteins actually are expressed at the
late very latest stage of infection but
are not required by for the infectious
cycle of the virus so you early days so
we use a particular virus system
actually and then we need us to use it
to generate a transfer plasmid and this
transfer plasmid with flanked by two
regions and have two flanking sequence
and that is similar of the same with
particular virus and that they are these
they are plasmid recovering the promises
I made occupy classical recompile ation
and then so this actually is open a very
very low efficiency and also in this
case there is no selection marker so we
need to rely on the experience
researchers to you
use their bare eyes and to see they are
to fight the positive clones and them
because after the poly syndrome these
approaches is replaced and we cannot see
this piece of particles anymore so in
nowadays I computer the invention of
this game called back to back particular
virus insects expressed ISM and that
makes our work much easier and this
purpose particular virus insect
expression system mainly composed of the
three plasmid so one is a parameter to
this magnet the platform is still their
particular virus but that is they are as
it's modified so that this polythene
group this region is replaced in
stability needed and replaced by this
lengthy gene and this also with a small
in insertion of this mode they are they
see a short sequence as transportation
and also we added a select genes and
then seven one is acne the taller
plasmid so that includes also two
similar transporting sequence together
with the target genes and also the gel
is amazing selection genes and then we
need a third plasmid that is erb erb up
help of plasmids that encode actually
the transporters and that is facilitate
the transposition and then therefore so
after we transform all these plasmid
into the bacteria this system and that
will compile Asian can occur at a very
high efficiency because these
facilitated transposition system and the
furthermore and the selection is much
easier so we can use
the system this election season firstly
so we can use a color selection because
this neck region will be in activated by
insertion of this plasmid the target
team and then with I use blue and white
color for selection and additionally and
this gelatin Khaled amaizing resistance
will also allow us to use their anti
particle for selection so therefore and
this expression system just have three
very relatively simple steps the first
step is to generate recombinant at the
parameter so you can synthesize your
total plasmid and dumped by any service
providers and and then you can transform
at this dollar plasmid directly into
this th 12-pack cells so these cells
already host the other two plasmid
including these and helper plasmid and
also the they are they are back me and
now you isolate at this recombinant
plasmid by the simple color selection
and the biologic resistance and then
once you call the purification and are
these back MIT and you can transfer this
and to your insect cells and I mean
adherent SS iron cells and then after
the transaction you can start to test
whether a lot your protein is expressed
and done by Western plot and all other
activity test and then you can harvest
the simulation at the first generation
of your virus and then you can amplify
your virus and this often takes two to
three weeks and the most athenaeus step
and that you can and will attach the
titration of your virus and then and you
get your virus stop
so the first phase is the optimization
and express and purification of your
target proteins and then for each of the
protein there's no acting I should say
and there is no standard solution for
the titers of the virus you needed for
you need for expression of highest for
higher expression of your protein so in
that case and we need to optimize what
is the base concentration and that
required to achieve to achieve higher
expression of the protein case-by-case
and then you can screw up your
expression system for example you can in
our case you we use a fermentation
system and when you use a fermentation
system and then you feel you can achieve
the certain city up to ten to the power
of the seventh and if you use the
concilium precondition the medium and
then after several days and you can just
close it cells collect the medium and
then you can do the purification for
that so by using this system and then
within several months that we are able
to express 22 autoantigens i mentioned
earlier and with a very high purity and
a very high yield by this insect
expression system as you can see from
here and then this is a date so we can
we are able to get the single bans for
most of these proteins and then actually
they are very hard to Express very hard
to purify if you use a clear expression
fission and then so by using and then
after we got all these recombinant
autoantigens from the insect cells and
we also tested their reactivity and then
using the immuno reaction to see whether
a lot as
of these Auto antigens can be recognized
properly by the other antibodies in
those patients with autoimmune diseases
and if you just give you some examples
how do we undo their validation process
for example so we come through to prove
also we can feed all these auto and
people are although other antibodies are
other antigens or recombinant other
antigens we produce either fix that in a
membrane that way simpler type of
membrane or you just bought that into a
membrane and then we do the recent blood
type of reactions and using either the
humans are the healthy subjects which
does not contain any Auto antibodies oh
we use all the serum from the autoimmune
disease and this has the auto antibodies
as you can see from here to these
patients they have these finger
syndromes and then this can clearly
identify the auto antigens we produced
using the insect cells but the healthy
individual does not have that and this
actually the patients with the mixed
connective tissue disease that can
produce is recover and antigen these
auto recombinant antigens will produced
and then they are show a very strong
positivity but it is highly specific by
the in healthy subject we cannot find
any positive signal at all so this
actually shows and this particular
viruses and expression system is very
powerful in eighth grade their high
quality auto antigens that can be
recognized properly by the auto and
endogenous Auto antibodies in their
patients and then are the words and then
we start to use this
at 22 Auto high-quality Auto antigens
will produce to detect a single membrane
base a t43 metallic detection of these
multiple autoimmune disease and as I
said early on because these systemic
autoimmune disease seven major
autoimmune disease
they are often interrelated you realize
on many Auto antibodies for diagnosis so
they are so they feel we are either
because for these clinical applications
for some of the hospital's they only
need the single marker dissection will
also produce is a traditional a laser
based detection measures and then for
this single membrane based detection
measures it works like that
so for fill are so we targeted in our
case for example for these seven major
systemic autoimmune disease and for each
of these autoimmune disease and that is
each color so we select several auto
antigens that is show higher prevalence
in the patients based on the literature
and then so and the other that so this
is see they our overall protocols we
used for production this membrane based
chip and then you can simply still they
another cellular membrane to enter a PVC
support and then we can dispense and
this different type of these auto
antigens we produced into these
membranes and then we call this autumn
and region invaded nitrocellulose
membrane code into our scripts and then
we generate this kind of script for that
and there you can see from here and then
so we
and we'll also use the micro fluidic
space
the detachment measures and then for to
facilitate the detection in this case so
we can complete the assets within 30
minutes so for example this is just
several clinical validation cases we
have validated our assets in over to 200
patients and with clinically diagnosed
autoimmune disease and then as you can
see from here and then for each type of
autoimmune disease and then we can show
very the diagnosis with very high
efficacy and then this SEO II you can
show the regions several bands and then
in they are with they are the expected
autoimmune androgen Auto and India are
very positive and then in the right
panel and you can see these fingers
syndromes and there's one very prominent
they also antibodies that can be
detected and in the second panelist you
can see these patients and with mixed
connective tissue disease and then you
can see these two pages they have two
different auto antibodies against two
different autoantigens so that highlight
is important to have these simultaneous
screening of multiple autoantigens in
order to increase their accuracy and
also sensitivity for diagnosis so they
actually we are also compared so these
are the other antigens we produce from
this and yields excerpts so we find that
there has much higher sensitivity and
also much higher selectivity than those
proteins
generated from the bacterial system so
in our case to our system can detect
seven and auto-immunity cities and
simultaneously with a single membrane
basically and with sensitivity of over
95% from 200 of clinical need policy of
Katies we have validated so far and then
because they indeed they I read hope can
be recognized easily by those and
autoantibody endogenous other antibodies
we are able to detect all these
autoantigens and then within 30 minutes
compared to a lot of these traditional
edges which will take at initial 90
minutes to complete the entire attic
with still a very lower sensitivity
therefore i a very short summary for my
talk so we can show you from our
experience and we are able to use the
system millenia expression system to
generate the high quality of biomarkers
and for their asses and which you can
detect their auto immune diabetes with
much higher sensitivity and also provide
the pathological insight and now we have
shown and that we use is per topic
particular virus and the insect cell
expression system can reliably express
other antigens that can be recognized by
endogenous auto antibodies of different
auto immune diseases and with very high
efficiency and then by using this
autoantigens producer from this
particular virus we are able to produce
a highest robot asses there can
simultaneously screening and also detect
seven major interrelated autoimmune
disease and with significantly improved
sensitivity and that also reduce the
detection time and thank you very much
for attention thank you
Thank You dr. Shu for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen
and click the send button dr. Xu and dr.
Zhang will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is is
there any other advantages of back to
back system especially regarding the
high throughput expression
thank you I think in addition to get the
hired expression of proteins so these
are back to back system can also allow
you to express to proteins in C my
tennis need to be used a pip pippers
pepto system so this actually takes
advantage of the two strong promoters of
particular viral system - including this
polyhedron promoter and also a p10
promoter so if you use that so you can
come to jeans and then into the one a
single vector to express the two
proteins and then maybe they are
functionally relevant thank you
now our next question area have you
compared the performance of insect cell
derived and bacterial cell derived
autoantigens in terms of the sensitivity
and specificity in detecting circulate
excuse me
detecting circulating auto antibodies
maybe this I will ask my coworker dr.
Kathy don't answer their question thank
you so we basically after the generation
of the insect cell derived autoantigens
we also purchased some very well
characterized back-to-back that detect
bacterial cell derived other genes and
perform their performance in validating
the clinical samples in terms of the
housing serum or the serum from the
autoimmune disease patient and we found
that the sensitivity as well as a
facility of house generated also alguns
are much more better than the in market
bacterial cell derived out L genes so we
are very confident about this high
quality auto allergens we performed
thanks
and it looks like we have time for one
more question now this is a two-part
question is there excuse me is there any
mechanistic and/or technical differences
in the diagnosis of localized and
systemic auto of your diseases and do
you have any Rd plan for diagnosis of
localized autoimmune diseases
um thank you so for the first question
so although the autoimmune diseases are
classified and systemic or localized
diseases but the detection method or we
know the mechanistic that Gnostic
solution is also based on the
circulation of the auto antibodies so
for example the autoimmune diabetes
although it's the destruction of the
pancreatic beta-cells the release is
also they also can release the also
antibodies like da da and the ia 2a into
the circulation so it is the same to use
the recombinant old adages to detect the
circulating auto antibodies and in the
future we are as we discussed before
there are over 80 different types of
autoimmune diseases identified in human
beings and majority of them are
localized diseases so we are actually
actively preparing and are developing or
we want to develop all the the
immunities for the diagnosis of all the
autoimmune diseases including the
localized autoimmune diseases so our
next product is about to using the new
biomarkers from the autoimmune diabetes
to generate a panel a series of the
diagnostic products for the autoimmune
diabetes and later on such as autoimmune
hepatitis and autoimmune inflammatory
bowel diseases and so on so that is our
future plan thank you
I would like to once again thank dr.
shoes for his informative presentation I
would also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through September of
2019 please share that with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye